some property developers in china are
going to great lengths to attract home
buyers
one offered cars and parking spots as a
gift
while another promised to give the buyer
a mercedes benz with the purchase of a
villa
one developer even offered to accept
garlic as part of the down payment
the ads suggest that for chinese
property developers demand is down
since the summer of last year home sales
for china's 100 biggest property
developers have tumbled home sales of
course are not just struggling in china
in the western world as well home sales
have been under pressure after a record
surge in prices inflation has become a
problem and fears of a recession are
growing but in china there are a number
of different factors
including concerns about the debt levels
of property developers as well as ovid
19 lockdowns china is the world's second
largest economy so anything that happens
within its own borders and in its own
economy has ripple effects for the rest
of the world so here's how the
government and property developers are
rolling out measures to help boost home
sales
china's real estate market has become
perhaps the most important industry of
all in china's economy the estimates
tend to be that the real estate market
accounting for between 25 percent even
up to one-third of china's economy home
prices had just gone up every year for
several decades it also enriched a lot
of property developers and had them
trying to race ahead of one another to
buy more land and to bring in more
pre-sales so that they could fill their
coffers and buy ever more land and that
model was perhaps most clearly
exemplified by a company called
evergrand that is one of the country's
biggest property companies as well as
one of the most indebted it quickly
found itself pushed to the brink of
collapse chinese regulators last year
began to take the most concrete steps
that they have taken yet
to try and curb developers debt levels
[Applause]
that created a crisis at evergrand which
jolted consumer confidence in the market
causing concerns about china's economic
growth as well as whether other real
estate companies could fall too
in addition to the regulatory pressures
developers also faced another foe in the
form of coven 19 lockdowns it kept
potential home buyers in many cities and
provinces across china homebound so both
property developers and chinese
government officials have started to
take some steps to
arrest the slide in home prices and
maybe even to perk them up a little bit
on the government side officials in
dozens of cities and other jurisdictions
across the country lowered mortgage
rates and made it easier to buy
apartment if you're young and on the
market meanwhile among property
developers they're advertising free
gifts with a home purchase some have
gone to even more creative measures for
example one company is giving out an
actual pig
while another is offering job
opportunities
the response from the chinese public has
been mixed if you look online you'll
find some comments that talk about
interest in buying an apartment but you
also see some skepticism online too it
does seem gimmicky to some people and
for many people the question is whether
or not they feel confident going out and
buying an apartment
the real question of course is how
effective these policies can be it's
probably going to rely more
on big macroeconomic factors rather than
on what freebies developers throw in or
what incremental loosening measures
one's city or
town has to build at the pace that china
has been building at for the last few
years
consumed a vast quantity of inputs that
were required from outside of the
country so any sharp slowdown that we
see in housing is going to have impact
on commodity producing countries all
around the world and so that is
something that people all around the
world are going to be watching whether
the chinese homebuyer comes back and
whether these developers survive and
thrive